5 25 into monday morning we have an
eight news now junior traffic buddy
nerd
alert now as much as we want you to keep
tuning in for traffic updates driving
you crazy reports there's a cool website
for the junior traffic buddy in all of
us
it's from the regional transportation
commission starting with what they call
their snapshot wall first page the
cameras along the i-15 resort corridor
but you can choose from dozens of other
corridors and cameras something else
really cool click on its device then you
click camera and you've instantly got a
zoomable map of the area each green dot
is a camera click on it like sahara and
decatur or i-15 at the speedway one more
thing the rtc fast fastcamp folks are
working on a companion to the snapshot
wall the video wall it's a work in
progress
and we've got links to all of this in
the online version of this and all our
stories at eightnewsnow.com when you
click traffic then driving you crazy
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone something's driving me
crazy email me traffic 8 8newsnow.com